25 ans après l'assassinat de Pierre
Goldman le réalisateur Michael prasan
lui avait donc consacré ce documentaire
un documentaire qui à l'époque provoqua
la polémique en s'attaquant en partie au
myth Goldman homme vous venez de le voir
aux multiples vies jalonné par un
militantisme d'extrême gauche une envie
de Guera en Amérique latine puis la
criminalité la prison et l'écriture nous
allons y revenir maintenant sur ce
plateau de débadoc en compagnie de mes
invités Michel présent est avec nous
bienvenue c'est donc vous qui avez
réalisé ce documentaire cette enquête
hein en 2005 soit 25 ans après
l'assassinat de Pierre Goldman vous êtes
écrivain et documentariste avec déjà
plus d'une bonne vingtaine de films à
votre actif je ramène tous ceux qui nous
regardent à votre filmographie
filmographie souvent engagée et à
caractère historique et puis précisons
qu'à l'époque de ce documentaire vous
avez aussi publié un livre intitulé
quant à lui Pierre Goman le frère de
l'ombre publié aux éditions du Seuil
Annette lé Villard est avec nous
également bienvenue Annette Lév Villard
vous êtes journaliste ancienne
journaliste au quotidien Libération et
c'est entre autres dans ce journal où
vous avez rencontrer et vous êtes lé
d'amitié avec Pierre Goman libération ou
à officier pierre Goman he on l'a vu
dans ce documentaire vous l'avez
rencontrre à plusieurs reprises
d'ailleurs on y reviendra hein tout à
l'heure euh et vous êtes aussi
réalisatrice de documentaire auteur et
romancière et votre dernier livre
s'intitule chronique d'une onde de choc
publié aux éditions de l'Observatoire et
l'onde de choc en question c'est Mitou
et là on retrouve la Annette léi Villard
féministe hein on rappelle aussi pour
ceux qui ne le sauraient pas que vous
avez fait partie des fondatrices du MLF
hein dans la seconde partie des années
60 Laurent jaoffant est également avec
nous bonjour bonjour vous êtes
journaliste éditorialiste et toujours
passionné d'histoire vous êtes
aujourd'hui le directeur de publication
du journal.info c'est un nouveau
quotidien numérique c'est doublé du
newsletter également l'un de vos
derniers livres s'intitule Le Roman de
la France de versin gorix à mIRABO il
est disponible aux éditions talendier
Michel
prasant je l'ai dit on le répète ce film
a été tourné donc 25 ans après
l'assassinat de Pierre Goldman et
réalisé il y a donc maintenant 18 ans on
va donc raconter ce qui s'est passé
depuis et ce qu'on c'est de nouveau par
rapport à ce que vous avez affirmé
notamment à la toute fin du documentaire
parce que la question que vous posiez
c'est qui a assassiné Pierre Goldman et
bien un homme a reconnu ce crime c'était
en 2009 devant les caméras de Canal plus
il s'agit de René rechini de S qui est
un ancien para devenu mercenaire qui a
également écrit une biographie où le
réitère qu'il a été bel et bien
l'assassinat de Pierre Goman tout cela
nous dit pas forcément qui en a été le
commanditaire et là-dessus vous êtes
interrogé à l'époque dans ce
documentaire est-ce que vous avez du
nouveau concernant l'éventuel
commanditaire de cet assassinat Pierre
Goldman oui alors c'est vrai que la
réponse apportée par le film est
relativement incomplète et il y a une
fausse piste qui est celle de ce Truant
marseillais Mayon libud qui
effectivement c'était accusé auprès de
Lucien éblanc qui était un grand flic
d'avoir participé à cet assassinat mais
je crois que tout ça est bidon vous
savez on peut pas tellement faire
confiance au Truant d'une manière
générale et c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs euh oui enfin j'ai
j'ai j'ai continué à creuser cette piste
je en recollant un certain nombre de
morceaux je pense que j'ai abouti sur
une thèse qui ne doit pas être
extrêmement loin de la vérité je vais
essayer de la faire courte s'il vous
plaît euh à cette époque-là Pierre
Goldman se vente dans tout Paris euh de
trouver des armes pour le TA donc le
mouvement indépendantiste bas oui ce que
vous dites he d'ailleurs dans le film
exactement donc il y a une partie de la
réponse qui est là mais pas toute la
réponse euh
et il va notamment s'envanter et
demander parce que il va chercher
véritablement des armes pour le TH qu'il
ne trouvera pas et il va s'adresser à un
contact qui est en lien à Paris avec le
that qui est un type qui s'appelait zizi
qui était le gérant de la brasserie
beofinger à Bastille et ce que ne savait
pas pierre Gman c'est que en réalité
c'était un espion double qui renseignait
également les services de R rignement
espagnol et les services de
renseignement espagnols sont serent ému
le GAL n'existe pas encore c'est-à-dire
le groupe chargé justement de traquer et
de liquider un certain nombre de
militants basques ils ont les mains lié
pour agir sur le territoire français ils
ne peuvent pas et donc je crois savoir
qu'ils ont demandé un coup de main des
services français les services français
très habilement ne vont pas
s'adresser à des barbouses classiques
par des intermédiaires ils vont
contacter des militants et c'est un coup
de génie parce que vous savez un Truant
on peut le retourner
facilement un militant qui agit par
conviction c'est plus compliqué et en
général il ne parle pas ces gens ne
savent sans doute pas par qui pour qui
le compte de qui ils agissent et par qui
ils ont été recrutés mais enfin on leur
demande de liquider Pierre Goldman de
régler le problème et c'est à mon avis
pour la faire très courte ce qui s'est
passé et après très habilement des
services français je ne sais pas très
bien ont ressorti ce sigle qui avait
déjà servi à plusieurs reprisesur de la
police hein c'était la revendication av
servi notamment à plastiquer la voiture
d'un militant ségtiste et c'est un sigle
qu'on ressort de temps à autre en fait
pour embarquer des enquêteurs ou des
journalistes sur des fausses pistes et
la fausse piste idéale à l'époque c'est
celle de l'extrême droite et tout le
monde va se jeter làin dedansou c'est ça
ça semble-t-il bien marcher en tout cas
simplement une dernière chose je l'ai
dit à la sortie de ce film il y a
maintenant 18 ans il y a une très forte
polémique vous avez des problèmes avec
ce film en réalité parce que vous
attaqué au mid Goldman c'est ça oui et
parce que j'avais ressorti ce témoignage
aussi de Joël lautrick qui n'est qui
n'est autre que son alibi ouais et qui
lorsque je l'ai rencontré je l'ai
beaucoup fréquenté il a très bien connu
Pierre Goldman il me fait cet aveu que
en fa réalité non seulement il était
chez lui mais que à leur d il est
possible que il ait pu se rendre à la
pharmacie donc moi je évidemment je je
tombe des nuus en entend dans cela et
euh et je je l'ai je l'ai
rapporté évidemment ça comment dire ça a
créé un émoi au sein d'un certain nombre
de de soutiens de l'époque de Pierre
Goldman de la famille aussi je le
comprends ouais et et un nouveau doute
quelque part hein cont sur l'éventuelle
culpabilité de de Pierre Goman hein
c'est ça qu'on vous a reproché à
l'époque bien sûr C que il a été
acquitté tout le monde était content
parce que tout le monde aimait Pierre
Goldman et tout le monde je parle de ma
génération
d'intellectuel de la gauche de l'époque
était content qu'il sortent de prison et
cetera mais le doute n'a jamais disparu
si je peux me permettre parce que
j'aimerais aussi laisser la parole à nos
prestigieux interlocuteurs euh il faut
comprendre aussi ce que représente
pierre godma pour sa génération c'est
leur affaire drefus voilà ou et à partir
du moment où c'est l'affire de réfus il
il ne peut pas être autre chose
qu'innocent et je le comprends il a été
acquité ça une réalité judiciaire une
vérité judiciaire mais à partir du
moment où ça peut être mis en doute
c'est une forme si vous voulez de de de
pureté ontologique de cette génération
qui est ébranlé et qui est mise en doute
donc chacun se sent concerné à partir du
moment où ils ont fait partie des
comités de soutien à partir du moment où
ils ont fait partie de cette génération
et qu'ils ont soutenu l'innocence de
Pierre Goldman et je m'en arrête là
Pierre Goldman je l'ai dit en vous
présentant vous l'avez rencontré à
plusieurs reprises moi je l'ai connu
quand j'étais étudiante à SAS à l'époque
où il y avait encore l'OAS il y avait
des mouvements d'extrême droite
extrêmement violent la fin de la guerre
d'Algérie fin des années 60 et Goldman
était le chef du service d'ordre donc à
la fois de l'USC de l'UNEF il était à la
tête d'une troupe de de jeunes
extrêmement violents avec des des barres
de fer et des manches de pioche et il
nous libéré parce qu'on était toujours
enfermé à SAS nous les gens de gauche
encerclé par l'extrême droite arrivé
Goldman et c'était Goldman arrive che
euro connais sur les fascistes et moi
j'étais donc jeune étudiante extrêmement
impressionnée par le personne la chass
c'est la première époque ensuite il part
en Amérique latine pour
faireia là vous le perdez de vue je le
perd de vue il rate complètement mes 68
il a pas compris mes 68 il était pas il
a dit à mon ami con bandit ça a raté
parce que vous aviez pas de couu en 68
voulant dire vous étiez pas armé donc il
avait un mépris absolu pour b68 on avait
pas pris d'assaut l'Assemblée nationale
on nit pas fait brûler l'État français
il il est passé à côté et ensuite je ne
le revois plus jusqu'à ce que enfin un
petit peu après 68 mais est en dérive il
fait des aleretour avec l'Amérique
latine il est complètement ouis on voit
tout ça dans le film ouais est-ce que
vous avez réussi à le cerner Pierre
Goldman c'est ça vra problème hein il
est incernable en fait pierre gulman il
y a toujours en même
temps tout ce qu'on lit sur pierre
gulman qui a réussi à rement vous avez
réussi à le faire vous à travers
l'amitié vous avez réussi à à coudre
avec lu quelqu'un d'extrêmement
attachant il a suscité un mouvement de
sympathie incroyable parce qu' d'abord
c'était un grand écrivain le livre qu'il
a écrit en prison est formidable je l'ai
croisé aussi quand il était à freine
parce qu'à l'époque j'avais un petit ami
qui était aussi à fre a révolutionnaire
donc on se retrouvait au parloir et plus
personne venait le voir il y a une
périodeun tunnel complet où il était
dans une grande solitude après il y a eu
le mouvement autour de son deuxème
procès et il a eu cet énorme soutien de
toute la classe INELL est-ce que vous a
ressenti une violence che Pierre Goldman
c'était un pe ouais alors moi je pense
qu' ce que vous voyez bien dans le film
c'est que il n'a jamais il est ce qui
est son passé c'est c'est son son passé
et l'explication de ce qui pierre d'e
famille moi je trouve dans le film
l'interview de sa mère que j'avais
jamais entendu formidable en polonne
avec une histoire de la choie
épouvantable les parents massacrés les
grands-parents la la grand-mère qui
protège les petits enfants qui massacré
enfin bon elle raconte ça que j'avais
jamais entendu ça et de l'autre côté le
côté paternel ce sont des héros de la
Résistance FTP m c'estd les étrangers
qui qui ont rejoint la Résistance en
France il est d'une famille qui a un
passé à la fois tragique et héroïque et
il est tout ça pierre
Goman un extrait du documentaire il y a
un passage en
Amérique du Sud ça commence par Cuba et
ensuite on retrouvera Pierre Goldman
avant
68 à caracass du côté du Venezuela le 18
octobre 1967 Pierre Goldman est place de
la Révolution pour la funèbre du
[Musique]
t il apprend aussi ce jour-là
l'arrestation de son ami Régis Debré qui
avait rejoint commandante dans le Maqui
bolivien c'est par son intermédiaire
après 6 mois passés sur l'île qu'il
rencontre des guerrier au vézuéliens qui
acceptent de l'intégrer à leur
groupe les vénézuéiens demandent à
Goldman de rentrer en France et
d'attendre leur signal avant de les
rejoindre à Caracas voilà alors jefin
c'est toute une génération ça se il
s'inscrit dans dans quoi Pierre Goldman
à travers cet itinéraire ave un épisode
de l'histoire de la gauche française
parce que au début des années 60 on sort
d'une période où le parti communiste
domine intellectuellement et sur le plan
militant la gauche CFI c'était considéré
pendant la guerre d'Algérie et donc
c'est le PC mais le PC a changé il est
toujours lié à l'Union soviétique mais
l'Union soviétique qu'il faut jouer la
coexistence pacifique avec les
puissances capitalistes et donc le rôle
du parti en France n'est pas de faire la
révolution le le parti s'intègre dans la
société française dans les luttes
sociales et et et devient un grand parti
de gauche il soutient mitéran 65 et ce
et il y a une nouvelle génération qui
arrive et qui trouve que le PC est mou
que le PC est trivial qu'il est
électoraliste ces jeunes gens qui sont
très il aur aussi eu Budapest 56 si le
rapport cou chef oui il y a eu ça aussi
mais c'est pas làdessus qui qui font qui
font s ils disent nous on est pour la
révolution ouais et Goldman est le
symbole même de la de deun personnage
romantique comme ça qui qui veut faire
la
révolution c'est un peu le tevara
français à l'époque qu'on vient de voir
tout le monde est fasciné enfin tout le
monde tous ces gens-l en tout cas ces
jeunes gens sont fascinés par par le les
révolutions sud-américaines notamment
par la révolution cubaine et et alors il
se posose de manière un peu à mon avis
fausse l'idée que dès lors qu'il y a un
exemple qui est chez Gevara qui est les
guerrieros latino-américains qui se
battent contre des
dictatures agité par les par les
États-Unis des des dictatures féroces
ave des exécutions torture et cetera
donc ces gens-là sont sont recours aux
armes c'est logique et donc il
transposent ça en France et et donc la
Ligue communiste tous les gens de l'UEC
vont faire siission avec le PC en disant
nous on est pour la Révolution le PC ils
se sont endormis
dans la démocratie française et donc il
faut aller beaucoup plus vite beaucoup
plus fort et al c'est là où on peut
avoir un doute sur sur le et sur Goldman
et sur la génération c'est que est-ce
que c'était vraiment très malin de
penser qu'on pouvait faire une
révolution armée dans la France Gauliste
des années 60 à mon avis non et la suite
l'a montré d'ailleurs puisque tous ils
ont arrêté ils sont passés il y en a qui
sont passés à droite beaucoup et puis il
y en a qui sont passés comme Weber il
est devenu il est devenu socialiste quoi
tu es réformiste et cetera ce qui
reprochait évidemment à la gauche euh
institutionnelle de l'époque et et et
donc tous ces gens-là euh euh ont ont
ont communié au au mythes de la
révolution dans un pays euh qui en fait
était plus ou moins pacifique et avec
une 5e République qui qui venait de se
mettre en place qui était plutôt des
bonir un autoritaires quand même mais et
et et donc le
le tout l'itinéraire de Goldman
vient finalement à mon avis hein
infirmer les croyances qu'ils avaient à
l'époque puisque on voit que c'est une
impasse que la violence en France ça n'a
pas de sens que c'est ça se passe ce que
dit Goldman ça se passe en Amérique
latine pas en France et que mais 68
c'est une pour Goldman c'était un
comment dire une une fausse révolution
et révolution bourgeoise hein comme ça
ça c'est pas vrai parce qu'il y a eu un
mouvement social extraordinaire en
et surtout révolution sociétale à
laquelle Pierre Gman n'a rien compris en
réalité que disais et et instant mais
les militant de l'époque le sentaiit
parce que j'en ai moi j'en avais parlé
avec Weber qui était un teroricien de la
Ligue communiste donc révolutionnaire
JEI dit mais vous vous étiez vraiment
prêt à prendre les armes pour pour faire
la révolution il dit oui non parce que
nous on voulait armer le prolétariat du
désir de s'armer donc il y avait il y
avait une longue étape quoi avant de
passer éventuellement un jour à la
Révolution il y avait l'idée il fallait
faire du travail politique il fallait
convaincre les gens et cetera et et même
en 68 c'est le service d'ordre de la
Ligue communiste qui empêche certains
manifestants de payer de de piller une
armurerie pour pouvoir tirer sur les
policiers il y avait l'idée on on
retrouve chez Goldman d'ailleurs quand
il quand il était dans un service
d'ordre quand il y avait trop de
violence le gênait on pe on peut pas
être aussi violent que ça on va pas tuer
des gens et et et donc toutes ces
générations a vécu la révolution mais
sans en tirer toutes les conséquences
qui étaient de la lutte armée quoi alors
ça c'est le Pierre Goldman euh militant
h
guriero du côté de du Venezuela puis il
y a le le à son retour du Venezuela il y
a le Pierre Goldman gangsterin cette
fois euh avec trois braquages donc en en
à la fin de de l'années 69 euh c'est
très bien expliqué dans le documentaire
et puis le fameux double meurtre du 19
décembre euh
1969 double MEUR de deux pharmaciens
dans une pharmacie Du du boulevard
Richard Lenoir qui lui vaudra une
condamnation à perpétuité en 74 le
jugement sera cassé en 75 rejugé à Amien
en 76 et là c'est le fameux acquidement
qui fera d'ailleurs l'objet ce ce
dernier procès he le procès de
l'acquitement du fameux film de Cédric
KH qui est sorti récemment dans les
salles et qui a remis hein le personnage
de de Pierre
Goldman au devant de la scène ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on voit parce que
le film est sorti donc de CD a beaucoup
de succès à quel point le myth
romantique révolutionnaire de Pierre
Goman marche encore parce que les ça
intéresse vraiment les nouvelles
générations j'étais étonné parce que
pour nous c'est quand même du passé mais
je voulais ajouter quelque chose par
rapport à ce que disait Laurent c'est
que nous quand même notre révolution
notre gauchisme en France a évité qu'on
bascule dans la lutte armée
contrairement à ce qui s'est passé en
Italie en Allemagne et bon on a eu
action directe oui mais c'était c'est
plus tard c'est autre chose c'est c'est
plus tard et c'est pas la même
veine non moi ce que je voulais vous
demander c'est on on a le Pierre Goldman
gangster hein premier al gangster est
sans doute un un premier braquage
d'ailleurs il a lieu au Venezuela vous
nous l'expliquez il fait gu he la sortie
d'une banque mais là pour le coup il
passe à l'acte en France euh la banque
de Puerto La Cruz est évidemment un acte
fond là on est plus dans le militantisme
politique là euh alors c'est pas
vzuela que il faut il faut se remettre
sur cette fameuse ce fameux mois de
décembre oui mais c'est un peu pareil il
faut se remettre dans l'imaginaire de
l'époque d'abord je tiens à préciser que
je suis Venezuela j'ai rencontré tous
les membres encore vivant du groupe de
Pierre Goldman Osvaldo bareto Theodoro
Petkov et d'autres qui étaient des gens
formidables il y a eu une erreur
historique c'est-à-dire que ils vont
crapahuter dans les montagnes
vénézuéliennes pendant 8 9 mois ne
livrait absolument aucun combat ils
n'ont pas compris que le Venezuela à ce
moment-là avait basculé dans la
démocratie ils l'ont compris tardivement
ils ont fini par le comprendre et très
habilement d'ailleurs le pouvoir de
l'époque vézuélien grâce à la mne
pétrolière va le les abreever d'argent
pour qu'ils rentre dans le rang et ils
vont tous rentrer dans le rang c'était
des intellectuels ils vont devenir prof
de fac journalistes et cetera bon Pierre
Goldman effectivement avec en gros
francs de l'époque enfin ce qui était
une grosse somme hein c'est le le le
braquage de cette banque à Puerto lacuz
au
Venezuela le braquage le plus lucratif
de années 69 dans le monde ouis ensuite
trois braquages en France qu'il
reconnaîtra d'ailleurs et puis ce fameux
double meurtre il rentre à Paris en une
semaine il liquide la somme considérable
avec laquelle il est rentré à Paris qui
aurait sans doute dû servir à financer
ou à poursuivre la révolution Vénezuela
ça reste une question d'accord donc ça
c'est encore le côté Robin Desbois
Pierre Goldman Robin Desbois je sais pas
je citerai pas son nom mais il avait un
un ami que j'ai que j'ai rencontré que
j'ai interviewé guadeloupéen à qui il
achète je crois c une Porsche voilà
décapotable enfin bon donc en une
semaine il liquide il se retrouve sans
un rond donc à la fois il a besoin de
gagnerer de l'argent et il ne voulait
pas travailler il ne pouvait d'ailleurs
que difficilement le faire en réalité il
n'avait pas de formation il n'ait pas de
diplôme réellement euh et il faut bien
se replacer dans le contexte imaginaire
de l'époque où il y a un lien entre le
braquage le gangsterisme et la lutte
armée l'un servant à financer l'autre ou
le cas échéant à déstabiliser ou être
une forme de terrorisme si vous voulez
dans une société euh apaisée donc il y a
pas vraiment un renoncement ou euh pour
les observateurs de l'époque euh un
revirement il suit une ligne qui n'est
pas la leheure mais qui se comprend dans
le contexte l'imaginaire révolutionnaire
de l'époque pour Goldman c'est tout
autre chose en réalité euh c'est des du
gang terrible c'est c'est beaucoup dire
c'est les braquages de proximité c'est
des petits commerces souvent pas loin de
là où il se trouvvem au moment où il les
commet parfois même sans grande
préparation presque sur un coup de tête
j'ai envie de dire euh il s'agit d'une
pharmacie euh à la butokaille il s'agit
d'un bailleur euh d'un payeur
d'allocation familiale vous savez à
l'époque les allocations familial étaent
réglé en liquide et euh ceux qui les
donnaient faisaient du porte- à porte
qui se fait agresser très sauvagement
d'ailleurs par Pierre Goldman et deux
complices et puis ensuite après
l'histoire des pharmaciennes le
lendemain ou ou ou presque dans euh un
magasin de vêtements tenu d'ailleurs par
un monsieur drefus qui va avoir un un
témoignage très très sympathique à son
égard au second procès ouais alors le
second procès George kgem qui a défendu
pierre Golman à l'occasion de ce second
procès s'exprime hein dans ce
documentaire c'est vrai qu'il y avait un
courant de sympathie en faveur de de
Goldman qui était relayé dans la presse
par des gens aussi variés que George
Conchon qui a consacré des PES entière à
l'affaire dans Fran soir ou Jean duutour
qui je crois dans ce même Fran soir Jean
duutour qui ne pouvait pas être
considéré comme un gouchau dangereux
disait que quand on avait le talent
littéraire de Goldman on ne pouvait pas
être coupable bon le raisonnement
pouvait prêter à discussion mais en tout
cas c'était intéressant comme
manifestation d'une sympathie qui
dépassait les milieux de la gauche
militante ça c'est
sûr alors avant ce ce second procès le
procès de l'acquittement hein pierre
Goman sort et écrit ce livre en prison
souvenir obscur d'un juif polonais né en
France il se vendra à plus de 60000
exemplaires euh grand livre c'est un
très très beau livre très beau livre
alors et c'est vrai que là il y a un
aéropage de de personnalités alors euh
les noms alors son sa claque hein Sartre
signoraet Aragon sautit François Perrier
pierre MZ France Joseph Kessel
Jean-Pierre chevenem euh et tout cela
arrive même jusqu'aux oreilles de Valéri
giscardestin de réconcilier l'extrême
gauche avec disons la gauche de
gouvernement c'est ça aussi qui se passe
dans ce comité de soutien ça n'a jamais
vraiment étéou
vrai aussi un syndrome che chez des
beaucoup d'écrivains ils cherchent
toujours le leur drefus parce qu'ils ont
ils ont l'idée d'être un nouveau Zola et
donc ils cherchent un innocent à
défendre le problème c'est que les
innocents ça pas r alors il faut quand
même
rappeler
dfus était innocent à chaque fois qu'on
dit c'est laaffaire drefus on est clair
quand même que drefus était innocent la
question de de Pierre Goldman je citerai
son frère jean-jaces Goldman qui disait
il a jamais dit absolument il a très
très peu parlé de son demi-frère mais il
disait ça croera une chanson après son
assassin c'est un mystère ouais et c'est
vrai mais alors sur la question quand
même innocent coupable on savait qu'il
attaquait les pharmaciennes parce que à
l'époque moi je l'ai vu quand il à cette
époque-là euh et c'était assez notoire
avant qu'il avoue que effectivement il
avait braqué des pharmacienes et
franchement c'est pas très Robin Desbois
c'est pas très glorieux d'attaquer des
des
pharmacies et ça vous lui avez dit
personnellement quand vous l'avez
retrouvé après son acquittement il va à
Libération et vous le retrouvez à
Libération vous en parlez avec lui ça
dans quel terme vous vous vous exprimez
auprè dire que la question de sa
culpabilité de pharmacienne alors que je
l'ai beaucoup vu ouaisbtion jusqu et ben
on n parlait pas il y avait un nom dit
mais moi j'avais une conviction qui
était pas forcément celle des autres
mais il n'en parlait pas par contre ce
qui était clair c'est qu'il avait il
faisait du des toutes sortte de trafic
parce qu'il avait les poches pleines de
cach à l'époque avec des gros billets
c'était cétait il avait garder de toute
façon un contact avec ses potes du grand
banditisme de freine ça c'était clair
maintenant il ne disait pas non plus
qu'il était innocent
coupable c'était fini il avait été
acquitté on n parlait plus alors il est
enterré après son son
assassinat 7 jours après son assassinat
au cimetière du PER les personnalité que
j'ai cité précédemment pour beaucoup
d'entre elles sont présentes à cet
enterrement vous y étiez aussi moi qui
écrit libération suivez-vous
l'enterrement alors j'ai lu partout le
geofrein que là c'est pas seulement
l'enterrement de Pierre Goman ce jour-là
en
septembre 69 c'est c'est l'enterrement
d'une certaine gauche et ça a été vécu
comme ça par beaucoup de monde semble
c'est la fin de cet
épisode révolutionnaire quoi pas tout à
fait parce qu'il y a encore il y a
encore en 79 donc c'est ça hein il y a
encore des mouvements révolutionnaires
c'est 79 oui 79 79 là vous parlez de
l'enterrement
de le le il y a eu les ces 10 ans donc
là c'est la fin d'une air c'est la fin
d'une certaine c'est la fin de l'idée
qu'on va prendre le pouvoir par par la
violence et par les armes et que il vaut
mieux euh au fond c'est c'est le la
reconnaissance implicite que les
réformistes avaient raison et que les
révolutionnaires en France j'entends
avaient tort et que finalement il faut
faire autre chose d'ailleurs la plupart
de ceux à part kvine la plupart de ceux
qu'on voit dans le film ils ont tous
fait autre chose soit ils sont passés
euh dans le la littérature dans le
cinéma ou dans l'enseignement et puis
politiquement ils ont évolué soit pour
devenir des bons socio-démocrates soit
pour passer à droite carrément comme
fikel crô par exemple qui est de cette
génération là réis Debray qui était ni à
droite ni à gauche mais enfin qui est
plus qui n'est plus d'extrême gauche et
cetera tous ces gens-là ont finalement
pas considéré sans trop le dire parce
que c'est un peu difficile c'est
douloureux même que ces 10 ans passé à
rêver de la Révolution mené à une
impasse j'ai noté quelques phrases he
Maré catler
à propos de cet enterrement parfois des
événements éphémères marquent la fin de
grande période Benjamin stor c'était
l'épuisement d'une génération qui était
allé au bout de ses rêvres mais
Jean-Pierre c'est c'est un horrible
malentendu tous ces dizaines de milli
gens ont manifesté ont suivi le le
Cercil de Pierre Goldman jusqu'au père
la chaise en pensant qu'il avait été
abattu par des policiers fascistes ce
qui comme vous on le sait maintenant
n'était pas vrai et donc il manifestait
pour de soutien contre al que le
fascisme en en l'occurrence n'était pour
rien et il y a eu la même chose un an
plus tard c'estàd l'attentat de la rue
copernque la copernique ou on a eu un
demiillion de personnes qui ont
manifesté pareil contre le fascisme
alors que c'était
Moyen-Orient palestinien donc on a à
chaque fois on a des mobilisations sur
terrible malentendu historique le
malentendu c'est aussi que bon c'est
celui de Pierre gonman mais enfin
entre disons
sa geste et son enterrement il y a eu
les bénéfices de Mai 68 qui a été
réellement une révolution sociétale qui
a énormément changé en profondeur les
meurs et la France en général donc ça
c'est pas non plus mais Pierre Goldman
il l'incarnait pas cette révolution
68 non il n'incarnait pas cette
révolution de 68 du tout mais il en
était d'une certaine manière l'emblème
c'estàdire l'emblème de de cette
génération qui va faire effectivement
son deuil des utopies révolutionnaires
et qui va rentrer dans le rang et
notamment dans le rang du Parti
socialiste pour beaucoup enfin qui
n'oublions pas qu'un an après François
miteran arrive au pouvoir donc et là
vous rejoignez ce qu' dit l'offin voilà
c'est c'est c'est c'est la fin d'une
époque c'est aussi l'époque d'une
réconciliation des gauches d'une
certaine manière et euh et tout ce qui
s'est passé on n'est plus dans la
société corsetée gaulienne qui a connu
Pierre Goldman très clairement ça aussi
ça change les choses bah ça sera le mot
de la fin grand merci vraiment à tous
les trois d'avoir participé à ce débatog
sur la base de votre documentaire bien
entendu Michel présent qui avait été
réalisé on le rappelle en 2005 et il
s'est passé des choses depuis et vous
nous avez expliqué aujourd'hui qui
aurait pu être le commanditaire de
l'assassin de Pierre Goldman en tout cas
vous nous avez livé votre test pour
compléter le film que nous avons eu le
le plaisir de regarder ensemble dans ce
dans ce débatoc vos réactions ça sera
sur hashtag debadoc bien entendu Alice
de branon est à remercier ainsi que
Sarah eudelier qu'ell m'ont qui m'ont
aidé toutes deux à préparer cette
émission et puis je vous donne tout
simplement rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat dooc et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très
[Musique]
bientôt